what is going on there reject nation we're gonna
watch an episode that i am very much concerned
will have to be blurred quite a bit because of
the fact that we uh being so many yellow dollar
bills on my main concern is not even the yellow
dollar bill signs anymore it's more about just
making sure this doesn't get taken off of youtube
or age restricted or get it community guidelines
those are the main real concerns right
now which is why we tend to have sponsors
on the boys so that way we can not worry
about the whole yellow dollar bill signs
but anyway the boys 3x6 we're here guys leave a
like that'd be very much appreciated also uh leave
your thoughts below on the episode down below
and subscribe and click that notification bell
to get notified when our reaction for the next
episode of the boyz is up here on the channel
full length of watch alongs where you sync up
with the time code are available over at our
patreon page for super sexy rejects go ahead
check out everything else we got to offer over
there as well also thank you tim and prepper
boys helping us add down these highlights and
thank you to storyblocks for sponsoring this video
more on them after the reaction let's get to it
together we can imagine a better world
imagine there's no heaven
yes
yes soldier boy no it's impossible he died like
40 years ago someone's cosplaying look at his face
homelander looks so disturbed you want
to tell the world that soldier boy hero
of heroes is back from the [__]
dead and blowing up midtown
before me he was fought his statue's
in front of the [__] building ashley
yeah it's not fair homelander why
would he kill crimes encounters
i'm really glad to have you with me on this one
we all deserve a friend like black noir
take out his chip or something
what a man i badass benny's it's how we won
d-day you know we were wired to the [__] gills
we're here to help you find your
way well i could find them on my own
do you know what a gps is or
bluetooth or i mean the internet
you made those words out
and all we ask in return is that
you add one more name to the list
name the homeland he's the new
you no one's the new me pal
but why him let's just say you're
not the only one who wants payment
put together an orgy the
biggest orgy you've ever seen
why did the photo go to you can't figure
it out something about being exposed maybe
i want charges brought okay a train persecuting
blue hawk will only make things worse this is
a time for healing i don't give a [__] i
thought we got rid of the nazis around here
nazism unequivocally can we talk okay this
later i have a lot going on today don't pull
out your hair or hair my dear my brother is
paralyzed i want some [__] justice seriously
let's not forget you also murdered yeah that's
right you did not give a [__] about all the
collateral you caused then now all of a
sudden you care because it happened to you
go [__] yourself oh yeah
that's right i said that
out loud
you go ashley makes a good individual
point about a train we think crimson
countess was just the start we think he's
going after his whole team including the war
the good news is that means we know where he's
probably headed next the twins tnt to the closest
vermont oh [__] you go there and if soldier
boy does show up you call me yeah what should
i tell the twins i don't give a [__] got
it invites into the herogasm for all i care
about the long face tiger what if it was a mistake
to take over vauden and they all know i'm a fraud
and what do you care what a bunch of mud
people think science want them to love me gutsy
so why do you keep running head first into the
same brick wall it's because deep down there's a
part of you that is still human no oh my god dirty
shriveled anemic little party that still mules
oh god well then my boy you can finally
be who you were always meant to be
a pure nature yeah like marble oh at least
he's getting self-validation from himself yeah
would rather die than be soviet slaves
afghanistan is ours and i'll stand by
our mujahideen brothers until the end
you know what else i'll do
vaught i'll distract you
the twins
scream i blacked out when i came to the damage
was done i didn't mean to hurt those people hmm
but that won't happen again
right only if they got it coming
always what you want to hear my sister's a goddamn
[__] and uh tnt right i'm a big fan of yours too
i always felt you got railroaded with that
starlight thing by the way you know like what
nowadays you can't even pay a lady a compliment
oh my god anyway we are just so pleased you know
you could hear it in the background yep you
guys having a party oh yes oh here we go
oh my god he is desperate oh my god he is so
pathetic who's joining us they didn't tell you hey
there holy balls oh no but there are 19 dead and
dozens wounded congresswoman newman what do you
say to the americans who are watching right now
and feeling scared yeah look it's understanding
kind of a nasty question is that nasty they know
when someone's telling them facts and they know
when the media is lying to them my god it is
safe to go out period yeah we're done here
nice hey uh are you free for a little catch up
no i'm a little slammed right now oh come on
ten minutes won't kill you oh yeah yeah
everything she says she's so scared
don't blow her head up please where's huey oh
he's just camping with his dad okay good oh great
i thought he was avoiding me or something you
know cause he was scared i was gonna pop his head
not gonna hurt you or huey or
your families besides you'd lose
you're all alone i mean come on
that hashtag home light [__]
that looks like you're in a hostage video
let me your influence and i'll lend you
mine i can protect you from homelander
and in return you help me goose my numbers i
can finally get my education reform bill passed
because she's better annie for my daughter
for a lot of daughters girls get it done
[__] you [__] homelander and [__]
vaught and this whatever it takes crap
i'm [__] done i'm not doing it
anymore i'm going to hear orgasm
hey keep this between us really tough to take
out america's sweetheart but not impossible
oh man
nice little tease
oh bad news bad news bad
news bad news i'm so sorry
friendship crap
his body is a masterpiece no
oh frenchy this is my favorite when sergey was
14 years old he dropped the glass his father told
him to kneel in the shards and not move until he
said so ah christ he likes to be told what to do
and he loves to be punished when he's bad
so sherry no okay make one no don't do it
you'll kill both of them and when you
finish screaming crying i will
kill you too how do you know
oh
come on can we go
yes oh yes
[__] brutal
no oh my god oh my god
jesus christ
yes [__] yes
oh
shot i know all i know is that if we didn't
check the burners three times a night
soldier boy would come back and
kill the rest of us oh my dude
oh golly it's back oh my god it's back come
in you are more than welcome to party party
yeah the 70th anniversary of hirogasm [__] me oh
you're not soup i'm with her for the [__] party
yeah they're going all out jeepers oh no no
more frenchie he's always wanted to see this
he's gonna be heartbroken a poor frenchie
awesome props to that stunt guy when soldier
boy gets here it's going to be a slaughter
we have to get these people out oh oh
no oh you're what's the fill alive what
oh damn
still a thing eh there's my
thing i founded it in 52.
oh yeah oh no this is a bad
luck man you better go invisible
what is he doing jesus oh no what are you doing
here nothing i'm not doing anything why would
you even this octopus was sick why would you
ask homelander is gonna love this no no wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait please please please stop stop stop no oh
i hate your mouth i hate the way your jaw
pops when you chew and i hated every second
i spent holding that clammy head i should have
killed you and [__] you sorry oh jesus no no
no you never apologized for robin i'm sorry
it's [__] up seeing somebody that you love get
hurt like that oh homelander is coming the
deep told me when those two start fighting
this could be awesome
television what it's gonna be
the best episode yet of course oh
yep you have to go no i need to stop
jesus christ all i want is to save you you keep
saying that but i don't need you to save me right
god forbid i help you because i always have to
be the weak one oh dude you killed my family
which one
oh come on man twins are up there so you
get homeland but i can't get soldier boy
you're a [__] hypocrite butcher now move
i'll come let you do it it'll be suicide
here's noira's idea top to bottom he gave you to
the russians please you i wouldn't take a [__]
without vats say so
no oh no oh no oh buddy
you guys are always away at the right time
oh god jesus christ not right
now there's a psycho back there
oh
you heard a lot of people you hurt my brother
whoa oh my god adrian's
really back your heart buddy
oh
damn
that was unexpected holy [__] yeah man
at least hide in the bushes
oh damn is that the end for him
wow i could see that being hit for him man
so long termite
what happened you happened
bruh oh [__] here we go
no william we made a deal to fight till the death
this is cheating heels off whoa you're the only
one that was nearly as strong as me buddy you
think you look strong you're wearing a cape
[__] knock off
i'm the upgrade
yes here we go
there
oh [__] come on butcher
oh [__] what have you done
oh god damn he's never
really put up a fight come on
yes yes
oh my god take that cape
oh oh this is sweet
yes oh you is in the fight
oh my god take him down
whoa
get out of here no [__] way
come on soldier boy come on buddy
they were so close
no no no no you were raised
man you were taught to survive
we cannot escape our own lives huh
i suppose no one can run that vest
damn that bruise they really put
up a fight god damn that's wild man
it's a lot of dead soups i'm in montpelier vermont
12 heroes and civilians are dead a lot more
are wounded oh she could earn vaude are going
to tell you that it was the super villain
and that they have it handled they don't
yeah oh man soldier boy doesn't care about
protecting americans and he probably never has
most heroes don't care about you
yep homelander is the worst of them
oh my god hashtag i believe starlight
he's done something to me i don't know what
they're gonna do to me for telling the truth
but i'm going to keep doing it and i should
have done it sooner i'm sorry oh i'm not
starlight anymore my name is annie january
oh and i [__] quit wow what an ending
oh here i was thinking we were
just gonna get a cool orgy episode
little did you know the real orgy
was the story sold along the way
that was such an intense episode holy crap yeah
um damn i don't think there's a post credits
okay all right let's shitty chat it's chit chat
well well well well i mean where do we get no
time to digest let's just just chat um before that
wow i got a lot of thoughts before that a
word from today's video sponsor thank you
to storyblocks for sponsoring this video being the
cinematic artisans we obviously are we are always
in search of ways to make our videos look better
faster and most of all for cheap cheap is good
and if you're a content creator or filmmaker or
anything in between you're probably in a similar
position it's tough to get your content looking
as good as it can be without breaking the bank
or burning yourself out in the process which
is why i heavily encourage you guys to check
out what storyblocks has to offer cheap is good do
you feel like this is their way of telling us that
the videos could be looking better yes whether
it's the credibility of an exotic establishing
shot the soothing comfort of the perfect music
bed or just the satisfaction of increasing your
graphical capability storybox has an incredibly
inclusive and diverse library of faces places
sounds titles transitions filters and effects
and more over a million assets royalty free and
available for personal and commercial use with
your membership sounds so affordable this is
quite affordable they have multiple subscription
levels to suit your exact needs whether you're
an independent indie solo creator or a whole team
so if you want to learn more head on down to our
link in the description box and get started that's
at storyblocks.com rejects now back to the video
thank you storyblocks she was definitely
not getting of time no matter how much we
import it ain't gonna happen man ain't gonna
happen so thank you storybooks um thank you
for supporting the channel like that anywho um
where to begin where to begin uh i guess with
freaking uh wow a thick episode uh first that
comes to mind that homelander fight was cool yeah
there you go that's the first thing we're gonna
talk about i didn't think we would get there in
this episode homelander versus soldier boy versus
huey versus butcher i love the way that escalated
you know first just soldier boy then homelander
then butcher comes in and then huey comes in
man he couldn't activate though we still
still don't have a good grasp of it
and uh of exactly how soldier boy's new power
set works but might have discharged a little
too early apparently seems like it needs to
build up a little bit or needs the right music
or something but when we visited crimson county
he was able to do it intentionally and he knows
what he did so it seems like that there's
two versions of that one is very intentional
and the other one is the blackout version when he
gets kind of lost like a winter soldier type of
um mind experiment thingy and then he does it and
he's just like he's even he was looking around
he's like what happened you know i know yeah it
was blacked out yeah um i like jensen knackles a
lot i think he's great as his character you
know he's just teetering on the right line
right line of that toxic masculinity yeah
traditional american like just a guy plucked
out of a time period but i what i think is
cool of how they're doing it because well
there's a lot of the soups in the show are very
like portrayed in a really nasty messed up way
um what you got with him is very different in the
sense of he comes from a different time period
where beliefs about people are very different and
that's what's applied here and he's being plucked
out of there put into this world and i like that
they're leading into a lot of those things that
are now considered very problematic ways of
thinking and that's who he embodies because
they haven't directly portrayed him as a straight
up you know direct villain even though at times
he's does some things and says some [__] like
when confronted with mother's milk about you
know the family and he's like which family was
that you know like the way he kind of shrugs
it off but he doesn't see he really seems like he
doesn't unlike homelander who kind of embodies the
whole thing of like i'm different than the human
race i'm greater than he's got a godlike complex
soldier boy really seems like he doesn't think
he's a bad guy you know and at least the way how
jensen ackles portrays him i really appreciate
um the way that's all done there's always like
a tension in the room when he's around like even
when him and butcher interact i'm always afraid
that like butcher's gonna say the wrong thing yes
take him off absolutely it's gonna lead to some
bad [__] so i i really think that what jensen
apples is doing is um excellent stuff and he and
and just there's something truly delightful about
seeing like the build up of seeing soldier boy and
homelanders sharing the screen together and you
got two very different american ideologies on
display here um where you have like the one
gruff and tough you know american hero and
then you have like the clean cut cape wearing
one yeah um and it is uh in some ways like uh
i don't really know if i would kind of compare it
to like a batman v superman or something like that
it's more of like a no it's just his own thing
you know it's like you want to keep drawing the
analogies because in some ways it is a little bit
of like an iron man versus captain america i mean
i remember yeah i remember just cap and bucky it's
probably the closest it is to a civil war fight
as it is but in terms of like they're both not
good people um but watching like the two time
periods clash is a fascinating thing a magic well
yeah it's like you got one who's overtly malicious
and evil and the other one who has yeah
some bad points of view and some bad
you know antiquated attitudes and a certain sense
that he feels you know above everybody you know in
terms of he's not really bothered when confronted
with you know mm's pastor or whatever else you
know he's very kind of uh you know low he's just
very chill about that kind of stuff but in a very
different way that yeah it doesn't read it's like
he has that menace and i love the different shades
that jensen echoes brings to him because it would
be easy to skate by on just like oh he's dean
he's back and and we love seeing him but here it's
like he's got such a presence and such a sort of
he really does embody that sort of man out of time
all american quality and he is a really fortunate
as much as there is like the obvious connections
that got him into the door for this there is like
a really nice parallel to a chris evans type that
he gets to mirror and play off of and i think he
is a wonderful casting choice for this and i love
watching like the scenes that he had with huey and
then you know from from that all the way to you
know the chaos and the mayhem you know it's been
interesting to watch this uneasy alliance form
especially because there is that quality where
so many of the soups are just outright scummy
in the worst way and this obviously is an
uneasy bond or an easy partnership but there's
something he brings to it where you're like well
of all these people to be partnered with he
does seem like one of the the least overtly
horrible to deal with yeah it's like you know the
shoe has to drop but at the same time you're like
well i guess if we had to have one of these guys
as an ally this guy's as good as any unfortunately
i don't know how the mother's milk
thinks he could possibly take him down
it's like all his method like he's just so blinded
with vengeance there's just not a chance in hell
he has and there's nothing he's done at all i'm
like maybe that'll work i know i almost wonder
either there's something else something to do
with the guns that he's packing that aren't
normal or or it's a death wish of his own of sort
of like i'm gonna go out guns blazing and then if
you know probably likely that's not going to do
anything so then i will you know be free of this
pain and rejoin my family basically i really
want to credit the writers and the dire uh
nellen nelson something neil i don't remember
who directed it but i really want to credit um
the the writers of this because they did a
superb job this episode around like this was
truly uh intense and and nelson craw croc and
craig craig um they did a seriously just a an
absolute wonderful job yeah because they you know
when you're hearing hear herogasm being built
up cause i thought hirogasm might be like crazier
i thought they would go even like way more
like balls to the wall a bunch of crazy
super hero stuff i mean there's only so
far you can go before you're just
doing something that's like x-rated
um and not even those boundaries matter anymore
on streaming tv it can though you can still kind
of it can go push to a certain point i remember
in the first season there was one time where they
walk into the club and there is like kind of a
taste of what a herogasm could be like when you
are seeing a bunch of superheroes at a club doing
sexual activities and here you know it's like it's
it is like feels like a full-on orgy uh but you
know like they didn't they didn't go as far as i
was maybe a lot of us probably built
up in our heads of where they can go
with this um but i liked how it wasn't about
that they didn't stop the episode to go
yeah which which they could have a little bit of
moments but in the beginning yeah yeah you set the
scene but yeah it's it's that thing of like we
didn't really get too distracted from like the
point of being there and i feel like they could
have taken five to ten minutes break just to go
crazy with stuff but at the same time yeah i
don't feel like i was slighted something no no
by the way they handled it so yeah it's it's funny
it's like it could have been more insane in some
ways you're like this is like a lot of orgy scenes
i've seen except for way more close-ups on certain
yeah and then a couple of power moments yeah but i
think what they did great i think the environment
created a sense of uneasy tension yes totally
so i thought using herogasm as a way to create
an unusual level of suspense and um was really
cool like because it's such a vulnerable position
to be in it's an exclusive event and you
know like when huey is walking around
and you know like oh my god how is this going to
go down you know and like this is such an awkward
moment for for violence and the the
percolating suspense that you know
soldier boy is outside and he's waiting to go
in there and you know murder a couple of people
i thought was it was a really great groundwork
to create a stage for some [__] to go down
you know so i thought that actually made it
more rewarding because yeah they had their fun
more in the beginning when mm and starlight
are first walking around uh look how deep
that's where he would go you know he's sick
best man loves well the heart wants what it
wants sick bastard sick bastard um yeah his
wife's not going to be happy about that but
i thought this was just a very
suspenseful episode like overall
and and with some great drama you know the way
they've been fleshing out starlight's journey
of you know i've been saying it since the
trailers came out that this seems like it's
a breaking point season for every character
here and i didn't really see that coming with
starlight to this extent you know when she's
uh talking with newman you know that's a very
tension-filled scene as well like okay now that
seems like the moment when newman is gonna partner
up with starlight and the boys but no she doesn't
go down that path either uh and then her her um
it's like i like when they use sounds like
a weird statement i like when they use the
physicality of nudity to be a very vulnerable
emote like an emotionally vulnerable position so
like huey and starlight having a nude conversation
out in the open where everything is coming out
i think that's when a case of like oh it's kind
of funny when you first see them there but really
what's making it even more vulnerable and hit
even harder is the fact that they are both exposed
fully in that moment and uh i like i like the
trajectory i think they've done a really good job
on handling this is the most interesting i think
the romantic drama part of huey and starlight has
been in quite some time definitely yeah so yeah
cause there's a lot of tension uh to grab there
but freaking homelander why don't you even touch
on him yeah why don't you talk about everything he
was going through here homelander with his green
goblins self-monologuing and everything it's been
fun to watch him yeah take the reigns of vot and
then have to deal with all that and get that check
back in to see how important it is that part of
himself that still craves love and acceptance
and that is still human because the further we
get into homelander as a character and the more
just unabashedly evil he becomes and the less he's
afraid to hide these parts of himself you know it
feels like we've gotten really far away from that
aspect of the character and like you said breaking
points this season i could see i mean he's already
hinted at it but you really do wonder that whole
thing with maeve at the beginning of the season
about you know release the tape if you do fine
i'll just kill everybody like i was wondering
how they would walk back from that and i think
they've done an interesting job by giving him yeah
all this status and all his responsibilities and
everyone else to look out for and you know it's
an interesting tension you watch the scenes where
he takes control like on tv and stuff like that
but in this episode you know like ashley tells
him off at one point uh even um and she doesn't no
i say train my bad uh but doesn't it doesn't she
she tells off the tv host she tells off the tv i
thought she said something kind of authoritative
to homeland i must be no i told off that she
showed off the tv host but yeah i mean just to
watch him panic and to watch him sort of squirm
and then to try and use these tv appearances
as you know his sort of vie for power
in everyone's eyes and then to have all
those things countered then later on in the
episode with this physical convergence of
all these people who are out to get me now
you know yeah it's a nice manifestation
of you know all the enemies he's made on this
climb further and further past the sun you know
oh yeah i mean i i like the way they used because
it was kind of mysterious in how they painted
uh homelander realizing that could
be soldier boy in the last episode
and then to see what he's confronted with
here because everything about what anthony
started along with the writers does in this
show is is so much of the it's still the boy
who was experimented on in this and his
body uh this superhero superhuman body
and i really appreciate that nugget that you know
this is a interesting trigger for him because uh
soldier boy was his hero growing up and then uh
to be confronted with the fact that he's back
villainous he's now the leader of vaught like
really really the the leader of vaught not just
the seven what this could do image wise to
him what this does psychological wise to him
what this does to black noir you know getting a
bad like he has that moment that's really funny
and i like when they bring those nuances in with
the humor you know when he confides when when a
homelander confides in in black noir says nothing
and then homelanders like i'm so glad you're here
literally does nothing and then
he feels abandoned by black noir
all bringing up those childhood feelings again
within homelander i think is they managed to
construct a really strong character like it's
always been character driven but they kept it
really character driven in an episode that i
think we all thought would just be balls of the
walls bunkers and it wasn't that it it they had
that but it was so played so much on character
you know like you have soldier boy who's um just
completely lost and he's he's in a world of like
different belief systems now and what it means to
be a man is what he's really focused on and then
also feeling hurt and betrayed if everything with
mm you know and i like the parallel that they did
because in season two is when they were on the
road is when starlight's the first character to
point out that he has ocd and then back on the
road here is when she finally gets the answer as
to why he has ocd uh with the traumatic memory of
the night his uh family was killed by soldier boy
i feel like there's something more
to that story that we're just like
that we're just not getting i mean i i don't know
a train uh i would be thoroughly satisfied if
this is the episode he died in i think this
would be a great way to end this character
i don't know for sure if he said i'm not gonna be
like oh what the [__] was it um but you know you
you see the that cause that thing that ashley says
to him like yes hey trey makes good points about
black hawk blue hawk blue blue hawk i think it's
blue hawk because black hawk is a dc character
yeah i could say that um blue hawk with um
everything he's confronting ashley about is true
however what ashley says to him is also very true
that okay now that it's something is personally
affecting him suddenly it's a problem you know
and that apology scene he has to huey it was
again like what they used as episode fours to have
everyone be so vulnerable and his apology seemed
really genuine to the point where it was confused
huey i love the way they played that really great
and it's true he never did apologize and um and uh
then when he does kill him you know i think that i
think just that would be a great because it's not
like he goes out as like you know a a redemptive
arc but he did the things he felt were the right
things to do he actually finally took action for
some motivation beyond his clout and his status in
the seven yeah because i don't feel like the show
is telling me to forgive him for the first stuff
but it he actually did something right i know yeah
i i wonder i mean it would be definitely a very
striking death for him i wonder if there's still a
story to tell in terms of you know what happens
when you really can't physically sustain your
power anymore like this seems like even if it's
not his physical death this may be the death of
a train and his abilities or something like that
like yeah i could see it either way i would be
very you know satisfied with this but again i i
feel like there every time they give him a really
good scene i'm like yeah like let's do more of
this if they train well i i think they already
kind of did some of that with atrium and
he couldn't run in the first season i
think what you're talking about though is what
they're sort of doing already with a chemical
of a character who's stripped over powers and how
does she adjust to life i mean you get a different
story with a train yeah uh a very different
one but they already they've already kind of
explored that with season one it's like a healthy
i guess i guess because it's a health thing and
they they make that so specific i wonder
but you're also right like there are other
characters we can explore similar things with
i'm curious i would see uh i think what this
season has done more than any other season
has put me on the edge and anyone could die
i was like huey could die in that scene right
there if soldier away manages to explode
um uh a train very well could be dead at that
moment i was like i don't think kimiko is going
to die but i feel like frenchie is probably
going to die you know i'm so worried i love
their scenes but i'm so worried for them i'm
constantly worried french is going to die this
season it just seems like it's headed that path
uh yeah starlight even like they could kill star
i really feel like they could just kill off anyone
right now other than like butcher now especially
with starlight now the gloves are off like part
of me wants to see that play out longer but i i
also like this season feels really tight in the
sense that like you get some really good emotion
mixed up with some really good tight plotting and
it feels like there's like they've maximized all
the room and space that they're using and there's
not really anything that drags or leaves you
know like space that much so i do wonder because
they're good at like hopping to the point like i
never would have expected this episode necessarily
to be the one where we actually get like some of
the things you would expect like to be leading
up to in a finale um and so yeah i wonder if
this season could end with her death or something
like that i think well i think the the use of that
fight especially there's only like two episodes
left right i think so i think that fight in the
finale what i what i think it does set the
stage better because even though we got that
that early then like episode eight what what they
what it does well is it with homelander makes him
um feel not invincible yeah he's properly afraid
now yeah he's truly shook up now because he's
probably angry and [__] but it's not only has a
mess with his psyche it's also now made him feel
weak and that's the main thing he's honed in on
is i am all powerful nothing and no one can hurt
me and come to think of it after three seasons
this is the first time i've ever i can recall
being like damn homelander almost died yeah you
know homeland didn't get out of there somebody
would have done something like that right take
three guys but still they got it done almost
yeah before no no one no one at all has been able
to do it you know um yeah i loved it i loved it
and and with frenchie and chemical um yeah
that's just so heartbreaking i just she's always
so worried that frenchie's always gonna die but
you know like with kim mcgo too you know there's
she blames her powers but um what was it called
the liberation army where she was raised she's
got a [__] up upbringing and it's like there's
there's so much i think so much of what this show
explores is how the the past of each of these
characters more than just frenchie and kimiko
everyone's past really haunts them and especially
with those two though because they're the ones
who it's like butcher has everyone has mostly
people have a tragic past undoubtedly but i
think with butch i think with frenchie and
kimiko they really play it like a tragedy
whereas like butcher's like god he's a badass
confident guy says the c word all the time he's
funny does kimiko and frenchy have something in
the in a different way than say huey and starlight
because they're differently positioned characters
it feels like frenchy and kimiko have the most
fragile and the most like pertinent current
right at the forefront situation that's yeah
he could like you know he's mortal she's got
powers but only so much and it really feels
like they are the ones in the most vulnerable
position yeah because butcher i mean yeah
he's got his i mean he's a lone wolf with a team
but you know he's got his own sort of inner things
to deal with and yeah huey and starlight there's
a whole other power dynamic there whereas you know
kimiko and frenchie feel like they do exist on the
street level yeah and are sort of yeah vulnerable
especially to everything going on and especially
because of their bond and that bond being so
current and them both being in a similar position
of you know not that this season they have to lay
as low but still like you know they're they're
not uh in the easiest position out of everybody
it seems like they're kind of the hardest
uh positioned in the boys core group anyway
well i think out of them all especially in
this season is that they're the ones who are
they're the ones who most want to leave
and are the most taken advantage of used
you know it's like mm keeps making the choice to
go back like they make their choices and [__]
but mm especially is a character who's constantly
you know getting mad at butcher and blaming him
but he keeps choosing to go back into all this and
i think he's doing a great job i'm always i always
have mad respect for like the super buff actors
who can like be super vulnerable on camera because
a lot of times you're like ah you're hired
because you're like a buff charismatic guy
but you know when you can be that grade
a of an actor i'm always like hell yeah
i love all of his scenes very impressive yeah
he's really likable and i like the pairing of
him and starlight a lot like when that chemistry
was really found in season two i enjoy seeing
carried over here i have no idea what's going
to happen it's been this whole season it's like
i don't know what's going on but it's been a
very thrilling ride that way and uh a season
this this ending with starlight is a game changer
could be could could genuinely be a game changer
and it's knowing the trajectory of vaude it's
like oh you kill starlight then blame her
in some way or homelander just embraces the side
of the people who truly embrace him because they
keep pulling out words that are so trumpy you know
when he's talking on stuff um so i appreciate that
and and i want them to kind of lean into
the corrupt side more of the the liberal
side the democratic side with the newman who's
obviously an aoc representative in a lot of ways
you know not the not the same ethnicity but it's
so obvious that she's a play on that you know
yeah so uh i want to i want to see that even
though i like aoc uh-huh sorry forever pissed off
um yeah this is a damn good show this has been a
great season this has been a fantastic season and
i i think it's been the most um hasn't been the
funniest one but it's been so emotional and taught
i love it it is even the hair orgasm episode
like not that funny you know like there's some
laugh out gross gags and [__] but it's not
the funniest season even this episode i thought
might be like the most funny one but it really
wasn't yeah it's really precise like when they
have humor it lands and they do a lot of other
things that also land and so yeah i think it's
it's nice when a show like this can do that where
it's not like uh it's not as funny so it's a
little uncomfortable now or something like that
like it still feels like the same world but yeah
just slightly less cause for humor yeah yeah even
in your herogasm episode which is pretty shocking
all right guys what did you think about
this episode leave your thoughts down below
thank you all follow us on patreon thank
you to storyblocks for sponsoring this video
and last but not least let's do a page
fox fox we're shouting on the boys because the
boys only has one strong girl as a protagonist
well a few you know you can't start life but i
was thinking like kimiko and i was like who's this
strong girl at our patreon who could kick an
ass it's definitely fox because fox is like
fox is like a base people savage because yeah
fox is mean feral relentless sinks her teeth
into individuals it's morbid just how horrifying
of a human being you are the violence this is not
gonna be a complimentary shout out you should be
arrested maybe thrown into an asylum or something
to prevent you from more violent criminal activity
dark abyss in your soul i really wanted to come
in here and be like you know you're like you send
us exercise equipment you're so physically strong
in all these things you have great enthusiasm
somehow we went down this path and i'm sorry
or happened you know what thank you for being
part of our patreon page for so long and still
sticking with us and being so support i
don't know why we just didn't say that
i get uncomfortable when being honest and then i
say mean things i'm sorry it's not you it's john
it's me i don't know how to take responsibility
for anything it's okay and that's john's fault
why i can't yeah i'm so sorry guys i'm gonna
figure this out and make everything better